hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring in this video we're going to
have a second preview to the huge a CT
math review video course that I put
together to help you improve your score
on the math section of the a CT so
basically what the course does is it
goes through 65 different concepts that
are important and helpful for you to
know when you go into the ECT and there
there's three and a half hours worth of
video there's gonna be opportunities for
you to do sample problems on your own
we're gonna go through them together and
you can go through the lessons at your
own pace whatever order you want if
there's concepts you already understand
of course you can skip those videos and
go to the ones that are more challenging
for you but enjoy the second preview of
the huge a CT math review video course
that I put together and if you're
interested in purchasing that check out
the links for that I'll have those for
you and I'll see you in this video okay
in this lesson we're going to talk about
functions so functions is definitely
something that's emphasized that you
understand on the AC T and it shows up
in a couple different forms but first
let's talk about you know what is a
function so a function is really just
like an equation but it's written in
such a way that you can see that
whatever is in the parentheses here this
x value that's the input you're going to
be putting that in place of X on the
right side of the equation so say for
example they say find F of negative 2
what we're gonna do is we're gonna put
this negative 2 in place of X now if
you're doing this on your calculator or
even if you're doing this by hand I
recommend putting it in parentheses so
that it's treated as a group so it's the
whole thing negative 2 squared minus 3
times the whole thing negative 2 plus 1
if you don't put it in parenthesis when
you do it on your calculator or even if
you do it by yourself when you're doing
that order of operations it could give
you a different answer unless you take
it as an entire group like that so here
we have a negative 2 squared that means
a negative 2 times a negative 2 so twice
that's positive for a negative 3 times a
negative 2 is positive 6 plus one more
so that's going to be 11 so half of
negative 2 equals 11 so it's just a
different way of writing an equation
instead of writing y equals we write it
as f of X or G of X or H of X so let's
look at a couple examples now you can
pause the video and try these on your
own
I recommend that to get a little bit
more benefit from this but do that and
we'll come back and go over it together
so this one it says that the function
here is given find the F of negative 1
what is F of negative 1 so whatever's in
parentheses okay that's our x value
we're gonna put that in for X on the
right so I'm going to replace X with
negative 1 ok now you can see I'm
putting it in parentheses and then we
want to do the order of operation the
PennDOT's which we talked about in an
earlier lesson you just take a negative
1 squared so parenthesis exponents then
multiplication that's important so
that's positive 1 because a negative 1
twice is positive 1 times negative 3 is
negative 3
that's going to give us negative 2 plus
7 so that's a negative 5 plus 7 which is
2 so F of negative 1 equals 2 now this
next example see if you can get this one
on your own
somebody's they throw this little
variation on the func function concept
okay and but it's basically the same
idea so see if we can get this one if a
triangle B equals 2a minus 3b squared
what is 3 triangle 2 equal okay so go
ahead and pause the video and we'll do
it together so if we're gonna solve this
you can see the pattern here whatever is
in front of that triangle that's that's
3 and that's going to be there are a
value right so I'm just going to put 3
in place of a and then whatever comes
after the triangle to the right of the
triangle that's our B value so you can
see B is 2 okay so really you can see
what the wave functions are work it's
just like a substitution it tells you
what your input is and you go ahead and
put that value in and simplify so this
is going to be 2 times 3 is 6 2 squared
is 4 times 3 is 12
6 minus 12 is negative 6 and you got it
so definitely understand how to work
with functions it's an easy one to get
right on the AC T and it's something
that they'll they'll be testing you on